it's great to be joined today by Chris
Voss who was an FBI hostage negotiator
for over 20 years is author of the
national bestseller never split the
difference he's currently a negotiation
consultant Business School professor and
founder of the Black Swan group a firm
that solves business communication
problems with hostage negotiation
strategies and Chris I think that's a
good place to start when I recommended
your book to my audience I could
understand that some might say well hold
on an FBI hostage negotiator that that's
not something that's relevant to most
people's day-to-day lives but that's not
really true I mean the type of work you
did and the techniques and knowledge it
really does apply to much of life
doesn't it yeah well a friend of mine
once contended that if you feel stress
at all you've been taken hostage on some
level so yeah it's about emotions and
emotional intelligence at a higher level
how did you first get into through law
enforcement into the negotiation side of
working with the FBI well I wanted to I
was a SWAT guy you know as we like to
say recovering knuckle dragger and I
wanted to get into negotiations because
I just knew there was a shelf-life to
swat tactical guys I had a recurring
knee injury and before I destroyed my
knee I wanted to go another direction
and to get become a hostage negotiator
that told me since I had no
qualifications other than I could make
complete sentences and even that's
forgivable sometimes and to volunteer on
a suicide hotline and that's when I
really got exposed this powerful level
of emotional intelligence and it was
just it was just too good just to stay
on the hotline to stay in crisis
negotiation I thought you know this is
going to work in everyday life too so
that's kind of how I got started is
there I mean within the FBI is hostage
negotiation considered one of the
cushier directions you can go in the FBI
or sort of like what's the perception
within the FBI about hostage negotiation
well a lot of people are attracted to it
because
it sounds cool I mean it sounds really
interesting which is exactly what my
reaction was to it initially also when I
thought about it I thought you know hey
I'll talk to terrorists I can do that
but it's a type of specialty that
different people are drawn to there's
really basically four kind of types of
specialties you could be a SWAT guy
could be a negotiator you can be a bomb
tech those are crazy you can be an
evidence response guys incredibly
detailed oriented you know negotiate if
somebody wants to connect with people
wants to talk wants to you know help
people with words and you know it's kind
of a it's fun to have that sort of power
in your book there's clearly a lot of
overlap between hostage negotiation and
psychotherapy skills interviewing
techniques behavioral economics you cite
the work of Daniel Kahneman and Amos
first czarsky in your books quite a bit
and I've recommended Daniel Kahneman's
material to my audience before but it
wasn't always this way
an FBI hostage negotiation was it I mean
in the book you described that you were
there sort of when there was a big
transition in terms of how the FBI
approached hostage negotiation well yeah
an hostage negotiation in general we
first thought it was straight bargaining
you know hard hard bargaining and you
know then on the suicide hotline stuff
crisis intervention we thought that that
had a place in in the contained sieges
but where we really made a transition
was when we used empathy and a very
intentional way attacked tactical way
you know in the hard bargaining stuff
which was the International kidnapping
we really made a big transition by
taking empathy and using it all the time
you know all empathy all the time it's
it's incredible how assertive you can be
in a negotiation if you use empathy
first and and we made that transition
and sort of merge the things mutated
being nice and to being tough at the
same time when that transition happened
I mean I think I could imagine a
situation where the guys that are
trained
to do the hard-nosed negotiating are not
necessarily the same people that would
easily transition to empathy and
behavioral economics and some of the
other techniques that you described so
was there a period there where there was
a big flux in terms of who was doing the
negotiating or by and large were people
able to adjust to the new approach well
it's a little bit more so you know what
your strengths are like if you're open
to learning if you've got the openness
characteristic and it is a
characteristic you look at you know I'm
I'm the kind of person I mean I just
want to know how to do it better if you
want to know how to do it better you're
willing to learn you can make that
transition as soon as soon as you see
that that's a path and some people are a
little less flexible you know the kind
of person well this is the way I learned
it this is what we always done it
you know those people have a lot more
trouble transitioning and there were
some of those that they get shook out a
transition they didn't they weren't
prepared to make the adjustment and you
know and go along let's begin now to
some of the different types of
negotiations that you've been involved
in in the book never split the
difference you talk about everything
ranging from a bank hostage situation to
international hostage negotiations that
could drag on for weeks months or even
longer tottering first from a tactical
perspective what are the real
differences when you're talking about
something shorter term like a bank
situation and some of these very long
drawn-out negotiations well the more
shorter term really is whether or not
it's contained a Bank is contained
you've got them surrounded
you know they've only got so much gas in
the tank they've only got so much energy
they can only stay in there for so long
and it's just understanding what the
process and the stages look like and a
lot of the process and the stages are
pretty much the same just how long a
period of time they take take place over
you know there's an initial feeling out
period of time of trust building you
know predictability building initial
timeframe there's problem-solving and
then there's solutions that's going to
be driven by you know people's emotional
concerns we
interestingly enough so many times
financial kidnappers in Haiti we're
going to settle that kidnapping on on a
Friday or Saturday because there were a
party on Saturday night you know Wall
Streeters try it you a make it a deal on
Wall Street in the in August because
they're all partying in the Hamptons or
you're not going to make a deal with
them in December because they want a
party on the holiday so it's beginning
to recognize the human nature patterns
that repeat but in slightly different
time for updates when you enter a
negotiation whether it's a negotiation
over an amount of money to release a
hostage internationally or whether it's
something more at the micro level to end
a standoff for example does the sort of
first set of demands from the hostage
taker how much how closely does that
approximate what it will ultimately take
to get a deal done well yet you know
it's going to be a percentage of it is
going to be there you know an
international kidnapping the the
kidnappers might ask for ten million
dollars that aspire to a million you
know there's going to be percentages so
they're going to be clues and you're
going to look you're look for the clues
and add it up you're looking for our
specific they are about things and more
specific somebody is you know the more
determined they are to get it and the
more vague they are the more it's a
throwaway you know how personally
attached are they or then also how much
you know one thing that was really kind
of crazy that businessmen and kidnappers
do exactly the same thing on if they're
really trying to defer responsibility to
somebody else that means they're really
influential and they're trying to hide
that that's been one of the more crazy
things that we found that's just an
absolute duplication between a shrewd
businessman and a kidnapper so in other
words if I know what you're saying those
who really wield the power and
negotiation sort of decision-making
power they will often make it appear as
though they need to check with other
people or that
it's up to somebody else right exactly
right and you know I had a businessman
once tell me that it was referring to
the decision-makers outside of the room
because a strong decision-makers not
going to get want to get pinned down at
the table so he's going to say you know
I've got other people have to worry
about you know I get a board I got a lot
of other people out here you know I you
know it's not up to me I mean I have
very little influence here that's it
that's a smart guy and I had the exact
same profile of different deference in a
bank robbery and also in an
international kidnapping so it's a smart
smart person it's way of hiding their
loot as the longer-term negotiations and
hostage situations would drag on what
concerns start to come up I mean I can
imagine if I hear your you're the best
guy you're here to oversee the
negotiation it's great if six months go
by and my you know loved one is still
being held hostage
I can't imagine as an unexperienced
outsider I'm going to remain as
confident in your skills how do you sort
of explain to the people that are
surrounding or connected to the hostage
that just because it's been six months
for example that doesn't mean this will
necessarily end badly how do you
communicate that well any negotiation
has a process I mean in in kidnappings
and business negotiations people try to
give deadlines to other people because
they don't have a feel for the process
and as soon as you flip over to alright
so this is what the process is going to
look like it's going to take about this
long they're going to get to know us
they're going to make some vague threats
as soon as people have a feel for the
process a concern for deadlines tends to
go away whether or not it's in a
kidnapping or it's in a business deal
and so it is and when you begin to
explain a process is somebody and you
tell them what the next few things that
are going to happen or what's coming at
you then you look like the you know you
look like a Mentalist you know a long
time ago there was this guy who could
supposedly read minds called Kreskin you
know I guess it shows my age
you look like the amazing Kreskin as
soon as you can tell the future and then
actually as soon as you explain to
people what's coming at them and it
comes true you then they do not fake
that they have a news incredible because
you can see the future
you know you know what's going on let's
pick up our conversation there we've
been speaking with former FBI hostage
negotiator Chris Voss you might recall I
recently recommended his book to you
never split the difference on the second
part of our interview we will pick it up
with some of the more specific tactics
and strategies that Chris is used we're
continuing our conversation today with
Chris Voss who was an FBI hostage
negotiator for more than 20 years author
of the national bestseller never split
the difference also founder of the Black
Swan group so Chris in the first part of
the interview we spoke sort of more
generally about your work and the way
that these negotiations can go in the
book you also get really really specific
about some of the specific tactics that
you would apply during negotiations
let's go through a couple of them which
I think will be really interesting to
the audience one is amusing silence
using silence you talked about this in
the book a lot explain what we mean when
we say using silence yeah well they call
it an effective pause for a reason
because it tends to be effective and
it's known when to drop a moment in
three seconds of silence which can seem
like an eternity if you have a hard time
with silence and you know some of us do
but it it gives the opportunity to the
other person to step in with something
good control freak negotiators hate this
they feel like if they're quiet they're
out of control and it's secret to
gaining the upper hand at a negotiation
is giving the other side the illusion of
control so you you help the other side
feel a lot less threatened you help them
feel a lot more in control themselves if
you invite them into the process as
opposed to push them into it it works on
a lot of levels and you know it's a
factor that's why we call it an
effective pause in psychotherapy
oftentimes silence is used by the
therapist to sort of allow and for an
opportunity for the person they're
working with to say
more where they might think that they've
said all they have to say or maybe they
are hesitant to say more even though
they know what it is that they would say
next is it the sort of same purpose when
it's used in negotiations like the ones
you were a part of right yeah you're
trying to get the other side to go
deeper you're you're trying to get what
you've just said to sink in really well
I mean the there's certain ago she ation
skills you don't want to step on so if
I've said something that is meant to
have an effect on you then I need to let
it have its effect which is another
reason why I need to shut up so that
what I just said will work and sink to
roll alone you do a little sort of you
recreate a role play in your book that
you had with I believe it was a Harvard
negotiation professor correct me if I'm
wrong on that
yeah babadook and brilliant brilliant
guy wrote a great book and in that sort
of recreation of the role play you are
sort of negotiating for the release of
your hypothetically held hostage son and
going to use that to talk about
open-ended questions what is the purpose
of open-ended questions
yeah and they sound so innocuous which
is kind of what I caught Bob off-guard
with because he says to me you know if
I'm a kidnapper and I've got your son
you know how you going to handle me and
I said ad you know I'm going to ask you
some open-ended questions now I knew
that sounded so innocuous to him that he
might be sucked in and he was like I you
know let's try it out well well you know
the world-champion open-ended question
way to say no which I've used on
kidnappers around the world is how am I
supposed to do that you know what I use
would use on the kidnappers I don't know
myself is alive and tell it always alive
how am I supposed to pay and that
befuddled kidnappers killers terrorists
sociopaths around the world and it's
just an open-ended question but it's a
very well-crafted one starting with a
very important word how people love
pants or how and so and that's when
that's when Bob said okay well let's
roleplay
and you know he said I got your son
million dollars by tomorrow morning and
I just said how am I supposed to do that
and I knew I had it I know how powerful
in it and I know it's particularly
important to say it deferentially and I
just I know how powerful it is it worked
it worked well that does seem to be one
that can apply to more sort of
pedestrian negotiations that one would
be involved in right I mean you can
imagine you you talk about buying a car
which is you know probably one of the
most frequent obvious negotiations that
the average person will participate in
at some point in in their life and the
open-ended question there and how am I
supposed to do that
that's one application that it seems
very very useful but what are others
that the day-to-day day-to-day life
might bring I got an email from a woman
whose thirteen-year-old son is trying to
get her to pay full price and buy him a
video game and she says how am I
supposed to do that it immediately says
all right mom I'll pay half I got a
client who's negotiating with a vendor
who's giving him a high price and he
looks at the guy who says how am I
supposed to do that and immediately the
vendor cuts his price by act just like
the 13-year old I've got a student my
class at USC negotiating on behalf of a
very wealthy person for Lisa home in the
Hollywood Hills at twenty thousand
dollars a month and he says to the
realer how's my client supposed to pay
that the realtor cuts the price I mean
across the board how am I supposed to do
that it's different forms have worked in
every situation and in every culture
it's crazy it is important though to
have realistic realistic expectations
right I mean whatever line you have
crafted going into a negotiation at some
point you've probably hit bottom and
you're not going to get more success or
I mean is it important for people to
have realistic expectations yeah you
know I'll meet you be flexible we
understand that there's always going to
be stuff that you're going to discover
your realistic expectations should be
that I'm going
be surprised at the table and you know
yet you have a question as powerful as
how am I supposed to do that is the idea
is you push to the side till they
finally say because you have to and the
great thing about that is you just
learned you've gone as far as you could
you're still negotiating then slim their
hands on the table and walk away so a
couple of skills in your back pocket at
any given point in turn and you're the
flexibility that you get out of it it is
incredible okay before we talk about
unknown unknowns and the politician that
that concept reminds us of repeating
repeating the last word or phrase you
talked about talking about this as a
tactic in the book as well talk a little
bit about how that's used in what it
achieves but we refer to it as a mirror
and this is not the mirroring where you
mimic someone's body language you know
if they put their hand to the chin you
know put your hand to the chin and
mirror is just repeating the last three
words of what someone has just said last
one to three words when you get to be a
real show walk you'll pick one two three
words out of somewhere in their
conversation but it's it really is a
closest thing to the Jedi mind trick
because there's almost an immediate and
voluntary response where the other
person's expands on what they said and
and go on that one takes some practice
because before you know how good it is
amount visible it is people who do it
feel very awkward but there are some
people that I've worked with it that
love it so much not only is it their
go-to skill they love telling their
people on their side ahead of time
they're going to do it because I like
showing off so it's incredibly effective
how does that differ from using silence
in other words in both your sort of
opening up the possibility of the person
you're speaking to to expand or say more
but how do you know whether the
mirroring or the silence is the right
tool to use a great question well a
mirror is is a very surgical approach to
a specific aspect of the conversation
I'm going to want you to go on about
something very specific silence is much
broader and although the other person is
going to go on
you haven't guided their thought pattern
in their head with a mirror
what I merely immediately guided right
back there
I want them to hit that target I want
them to expand specifically on that
target I use a mirror a lot of times in
place of the question what did you mean
by XYZ you know if they talked about
shad racks I could say what's a shad
wreck or I could say shadow axe and
they'd be like yeah shad racket and then
they would go on okay so a lot of these
tactics in the book lead up to one of
the sort of key aspects of negotiating
negotiation success which you call and
others call Black Swan the Nassim Taleb
wrote a book of the Black Swan which
talks about this quite a bit and in that
context you talk about unknown unknowns
and many people will remember Bush
Secretary of Defense Donald Rumsfeld who
talked about there's the known knowns
and the known unknowns you know that
whole thing it eventually gets two
unknown unknowns there was actually
something pretty interesting in Donald
Rumsfeld
sort of division of knowledge into those
four categories when you talk about
unknown unknowns and black swans
what's the importance well the where
they reside really is every Saturday go
she Asians get cards they're holding
there's stuff that I'm keeping to myself
that you don't know about or you don't
know about how I feel about it
the unknown unknowns are when where my
hidden cards overlap with your hidden
cards there's no way we can figure that
out because we're both hiding stuff from
each other and another aspect of that
also is you know knowing how people lie
won't show you where these are because
you don't know there's a they're
important and you only lie or hide or
give me poker tells about stuff that you
know to be important which is another
reason why detecting deception is at
best get you only halfway there you got
to get people talking so that you'll say
something in a little conversation and I
had no idea was a possibility and you
didn't know it was important because you
don't know what I'm hiding for me and
then in the midst of those moments
that's what we have the opportunity to
create great deals what's an example of
that from a hostage negotiation that you
could tell our audience well a hostage
at every given point in time you know
what's really driving the guy on the
other side is always going to be there
and we're not going to be sure what's
going on the bank robber with hostages
the unknown unknown in that one in
particular was there was a there was an
accomplice that we had no idea was
involved that escaped before we the
police arrived we thought we had we
thought we had two bank robbers in that
particular hostage taking in through the
course of the conversation when I was
pressing the bank robber about a vehicle
outside that was registered in his name
and I figured he was a driver in the
midst of the conversation and it came
back after I mirrored he's you know he
said you chased my driver away and I
made and it caught me off guard so I by
accident I married I said we traced your
driver away he goes yeah when he saw the
police he ran you know the unknown at
that point in time was our bank robber
wasn't his driving his own vehicle and
he blurted that out as a result of a
mere because marriage created voluntary
responses you know people blurt things
out but they don't think about so that
was that the Chase Bank didn't know no
no there was an accomplice we had no
idea was there once again the book is
never split the difference we've been
speaking with the books author Chris
Voss former FBI hostage negotiator
founder of the Black Swan group Chris
thanks so much for talking to me about
your work it's absolutely been my
pleasure thanks for having the
conversation with me